NOTICE THAT THE CENTS A LARGE
HERE WITH US NOW.
ANY TIME YOU ARE READY SENATOR
YOU MAY PROCEED YOU HAVE SP.
TWO FORTY FOUR THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AMBER'S MEMBERS YOU
HAVE --
VOTING ON A MUCH MORE EXPENSIVE
BILL THIS BILL IF I'M SERIOUS
EITHER UP BEFORE WE PROCEED CAN
I JUST AS TOUGH AS QUORUM SAID
ABSOLUTELY.
OUT MADAM [inaudible]
SECRETARY.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL CHAO HERE
KILEY [inaudible]
BAKER [inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
CALDERON [inaudible]
GABRIEL [inaudible]
IRWIN.
MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE HERE RAYOS.
FIGURE MATCHA HYPOTHESIZE NOT
BIGGEST TROUT PRECEDED UP
MEMBERS S. B. TWO FOUR FOUR WILL
PROTECT THE PERSONAL INFORMATION
OF ALL INDIVIDUALS.
THAT IS COLLECTED.
AND OBTAINED AND LOCAL AGENCIES
FOREIGN MINISTER OF A PUBLIC
PROGRAMS THE AMENDMENTS
SIGNIFICANT NARROW THE SCOPE OF
THE BILL BY REMOVING THE
BUSINESS PROFESSIONS EDUCATION.
AND HEALTH AND SAFETY --
SECTIONS OF THE BILL IS MUCH
NARROWER AND RESPECT THAT'S
RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
RICHARD MEMBERS KEVIN BAKER FOR
THE AMERICAN CIVIL LIBERTIES
UNION A CALIFORNIA WERE CO
SPONSOR OF THE BILL HAS.
MR LAR INDICATED THIS IS A MUCH
REDUCED VERSION OF THE BILL --
AFTER CONSULTATION WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION TO KIND OF TARGET
THIS ON JUST THOSE PROGRAMS
WHERE --
WHICH WE CAN DOWN MAKE SOME
STEPS TO PROVIDE SOME PROTECTION
OF PRIVACY WHILE ALLOWING THOSE
GOVERNMENT ENTITIES TO PERFORM
THEIR IMPORTANT FUNCTIONS I'M
ASKING HER ABOUT.
GREAT NEXT WITNESS PLACE GINA
THIS OF A GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
DIRECTOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER ONE ECHO
THE COMMENTS BY CO SPONSOR AND
ALSO POINT OUT THAT THE BILL
REALLY ADDRESSES.
AND PROVIDE SOME INSURANCE
ASSURANCES TO THE IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITY PRETTY GOOD DRIVERS
LICENSE HOLDERS AT THIS REALLY
CRITICAL JUNCTURE SO WE URGE
YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT PLACER.
COME ON UP.
SEE NINE OPPOSITION.
SEEING NINE OH LET'S BREAK
GROUPS ONE PERSON IS
[inaudible]
COMING UP [inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
BRITISH AMATEUR ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION.
SPECKLING OPPOSITION TO THIS
SPELL AND WHERE WAS I INTRODUCED
LAST YEAR WE HAD VERY FRUITFUL
CONVERSATION WITH AUTHORS OFFICE
AND MADE OUR OPPOSITION ON TO
HIM WHAT OUR CONCERNS WERE.
UNFORTUNATELY THE LATEST
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE TAKEN LAST
WEEK DO NOT RESOLVE ARE
CONCERNED SO WE MIGHT AND WE
MUST REMAIN IN UP IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BALLOT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
COMMENTS.
SEEN AND THE RECOMMENDATION IS
TO PASS A WHICH I LIKE TO CLOSE
PICURIS PREPARES FOR ABOUT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
MOTIONS THE PASTOR JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE CHAO HIGH CHAO AYE
KILEY [inaudible]
BAKER.
BAKER NOW BERMAN.
CALDERON.
CALDERON AYE GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I IRWIN IRWIN AYE
MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE NOTORIOUS.
YOU HAVE FOUR VOTES FOR THE TWO
WILL LEAD DEVELOPMENT AGAINST
HER MEMBERS THANK YOU SENATOR
[inaudible]
WELCOME SENATORS.
WE HAVE ELEVEN ELEVENTH TWENTY
ONE AND BEFORE WE START --
I LIKE.
TO CLARIFY A FEW THINGS SO.
BECAUSE OF THAT PROCEDURE TIMING
ISSUE THE AUTHOR.
AND COMMITTEE HAVE AGREED TO
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE PRINT POP
PROCESS YESTERDAY AND ARE IN
PRINT TODAY.
THIS WAS DONE TO ENSURE THAT THE
BILL CAN BE HEARD IN A TIMELY
MANNER IN THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE NEXT.
I SHOULD THIS COMMITTEE PASSED
THE BILL --
TO BE CLEAR THE AMENDMENTS HAVE
BEEN DISCUSSED IN DENOUNCES WELL
IN ANTICIPATION OF TODAY'S
HEARING --
SPECIFICALLY THE AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS ARE REFLECTIVE OF THE
FIRST THREE SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS
INDIAN ALICE'S ON PAGES SEVEN
THREE EIGHT UNDER COMMENT.
FOR ITEM NUMBER FOUR ON
CORRECTING TO DELAY
IMPLEMENTATION AND A SEPARATE
SUGGESTION TO ADD CLARIFYING
LANGUAGE TO AB.
THREE SEVEN FIVE ON THE ISSUE OF
ADVERTISING WILL NEED TO BE
REVISITED NEXT YEAR.
AS THE CLEAN UP EFFORT TO AB
THREE SEVENTY FIVE ARE
CONTINUES.
SO I THINK THE AUTHOR FOR TAKING
THESE AMENDMENTS AND FOR THE
WORK BETWEEN THIS OFFICE IN THE
STAKEHOLDERS OVER THE SUMMER TO
GET THIS CLEAN UP VEHICLE TO
THIS POINT.
AND WITH THAT LET ME TURN IT
OVER TO THE AUTHOR HOW TO
PRESENT ABOUT SENATORS.
TERRIFIC THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS.
A FIRST I WANT --
TO I TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY I
WOULD HAVE THIS CLEAN UP BILL IF
IT HADN'T BEEN FOR THE GREAT
WORK OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAO AND
HIS STAFF.
AND CENTER HERTZBERG AND HIS
STAFF.
AND AS A KIND OF WOUND DOWN HERE
TO WHERE WE ARE TODAY --
IT GOT A LITTLE BIT DICEY FROM
TIME TO TIME BUT I THINK
ULTIMATELY THIS IS HOW THE
HOUSES SHOULD WORK TOGETHER.
AND I THINK --
HOPEFULLY WE CAN USE THIS AND
EGGS AS AN EXAMPLE AS WE WIND
DOWN ON ON OTHER ISSUES I LIKE
TO THINK THAT --
BAKER STAFF IN THE PRO TEM STAFF
FOR COMING TOGETHER --
ON THE LANGUAGE THAT WE HAVE
HERE BEFORE US TODAY.
BUT EARLIER THIS YEAR I WAS
PROUD TO CO AUTHORED YOU KNOW A
I CALIFORNIA CONSUMER PRIVACY
ACT TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WITH
THAT.
CENTER HERTZBERG CHAIRMAN CHAO
WITHOUT ACT CALIFORNIA LEADS THE
WAY CONSUMER PRIVACY
[inaudible]
PROTECTION.
IN ORDER TO ASSURE THAT THE ACT
IS STRONG CLEAR AS POSSIBLE S.
B. ELEVEN TWENTY ONE WAS
DESIGNATED.
AS THE VEHICLE FOR
CLARIFICATIONS.
THAT THE AUTHORS AGREED TO WHEN
S. B. AB THREE SEVENTY FIVE WAS
PASSED.
IN THE WEEKS SINCE EIGHTY THREE
SEVENTY FIVE WAS SIGNED INTO LAW
MY OFFICE SENATOR HERTZBERG
OFFICE.
CHAIRS OPPOSITE COMMITTEE STAFF
OF ON THAT WITH DOZENS OF
STAKEHOLDERS DISCUSSING AN
INCREDIBLE VARIETY OF ISSUES A
PROPOSED CHANGES THE CALIFORNIA.
CONSUMER PRIVACY ACT.
AS HE ANALYSIS DALLAS'S NOTES
THIS BILL NOW REFLECTS
AGREEMENTS REACHED.
BETWEEN THE AUTHORS OF AB THREE
SEVENTY FIVE AND S. B. ELEVEN
TWENTY ONE AND STAKEHOLDERS ON A
VARIETY OF ISSUES CONSISTENT
WITH THE COMMITMENT.
OF THE AUTHORS WHEN THIS BILL
WAS HEARD IN THE COMMITTEE LAST
MONTH [inaudible]
A SPECIFICALLY [inaudible]
YOU KNOW.
I THINK SINCE ARE SO MANY PEOPLE
HERE THAT YOU GUYS ALL HAVE THIS
LANGUAGE I MEAN AND I NOT READ
ALL THIS TODAY.
BUT I THINK THAT THE OUT LAST
NIGHT'S --
ADDITONAL AMENDMENTS WERE WERE
MADE AND IT DELETED NOTIFICATION
REQUIREMENTS THE AG BEFORE
CONSUMER COULD FILE ACTION.
IT MAKES TECHNICAL FIX FIXES IT
ADDS MORE CLARIFYING FLYING WILL
LIVE.
CLARIFYING LANGUAGE REGARDING
HIP BUT AND WE BELIEVE THAT
THESE CHANGES THOUGHTFULLY
ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES THEY CANNOT
WAIT TILL NEXT YEAR WHILE
PROTECTING PRIVACY RIGHTS NOW.
UP FOR CALIFORNIANS.
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIGHT TAKE YOUR
MUCH AS SENATOR DR LET'S TURN TO
SENATOR HERTZBERG.
NOW HE WAS CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I
THINK IT WOULD BE FAIR TO SAY.
THAT EVEN AMONG THE MOST
EXPERIENCED SUCH ADVOCATES AND
MEMBERS.
THAT THIS PROCESS.
HAS BEEN UNIQUE FOR SERIES OF
REASONS.
ARM AND SO THE CORE OF THAT
UNIQUENESS WAS.
TOO WAS TO BIT BAKIN THIS
FRAMEWORK BUT TIME.
TO THINK THROUGH.
ALL OF THE COMPLEXITIES OF
PRIVACY.
SO WE HAVE A YEAR BEFORE YOUR
COMMITTEE TO REALLY DESCRIBE
THIS AND ANALYZE THIS AND OF
COURSE.
WHAT WE FOUND ALL OF US YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN MR DOT MYSELF?
WAS THAT EVERY ADVOCATE UNDER
THE SUN EITHER A TRY --
TO PUT BELTS AND SUSPENDERS AS
TO THINGS THAT RELATE TO THEIR
INDUSTRY.
I WANTED TO MAKE FURTHER CHANGES
IN THE UNDERLYING NOTION WAS.
THAT WILL BE FOR NEXT YEAR.
AND SO THAT IS IS THAT MR DOT
INDICATED THE AUTHOR AT BUT THIS
MEASURE WE I THINK.
TOOK DE DID DEALT WITH A LOT OF
PRESSURE OF A LOT OF FOLKS AND
REALLY DEALT WITH THE FOR
UNDERLYING ISSUES.
WE HAD IN THE HIPAA PROVISIONS
CERTAINLY THE A. G. TIMING
ISSUES AND THE EXTENSION.
WELL ISSUES IN THE PREEMPTION
ISSUES THAT WE FELT WERE SO
OVERWHELMING A TO MAKE THIS
HAPPEN BUT I JUST WANNA.
THANK MR DOT ORG THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN YOU STAFF OF FOR
ALL THE TIME AND EFFORT THIS IS
GOING TO BE A BURDEN ONGOING
ISSUE AND I THINK THAT.
THE UNDERLYING ARCHITECTURE OF
THIS AND CONTENTS.
BUT THAT WE WANTED A THE THE
BALLOT MEASURE OFF THE BALLOT
WAS BECAUSE IT IMPOSED A SUCH A
HIGH THRESHOLD OF A VOTE THAT
BASICALLY TOOK THE LEGISLATURE.
OUT OF THE DISCUSSION OF PRIVACY
WHICH IS GOING TO AYE AYE IN
YOUR PRIVACY IS BEEN IS AROUND
US FOR A LONG TIME.
IS GOING TO CONTINUE TO BE A
DYNAMIC ISSUE FROM WHICH THIS
BODY NEEDS TO ENGAGE.
AND SO WITH THAT.
I THANK YOU AGAIN THANK MISTER
GOD AND TO ASK YOUR SUPPORT OF
THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE THANK YOU
FOR TAKING THE AMENDMENTS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OUT ADDITIONAL.
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT PLACER
CAVORT.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS SENATORS HERTZBERG AND
DIED -- I'M
SARAH BOOTH CAO CHAMBER
TESTIFYING TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
SB.
ELEVEN TWENTY ONE EARLIER THIS
MONTH WE SUBMITTED A LETTER TO
THE AUTHORS OF THE CALIFORNIA
CONSUMER PRIVACY ACT PROPOSING
AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS DRAFTING
ERRORS AS WELL AS TO SPECS
ASPECTS OF THE LAW THAT WOULD
BE.
UNWORKABLE OR RESULT IN NEGATIVE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES WE WANT
TO THANK YOU MISTER DODD MISTER
CHAIRMAN MISTER HERTZBERG --
FOR THE FIXES THAT YOU ARE
ADDRESSING NOW WITH S. B. ELEVEN
TWENTY ONE INCLUDING INSURING
THAT THE LOCAL PREEMPTION
LANGUAGE TAKES EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY CLARIFYING THAT THE
C. CPA'S PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION
ONLY APPLIES.
TO THE DATA BREACH LIABILITIES
SECTION.
CLARIFYING EXEMPTIONS FOR THE
GRAMM LEACH BLILEY ACT THE DRY
DRIVERS PRIVACY PROTECTION ACT
AND HELP US.
EXTENDING THE AGES RULE MAKING
TIME FRAME AND DELAYING
ENFORCEMENT OF THE C. CPA.
WHICH IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE MANY
OF THE ISSUES WE REYES ARE NOT
ADDRESSED IN S. B. ELEVEN TWENTY
ONE AND MORE CONCERNS WITH THE
C. CPA WILL LIKELY COME TO
LIGHT.
AS BUSINESSES PLAN FOR
COMPLIANCE.
THAT'S WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHORS OF THE C. CPA AND THEIR
STAFF ON A REMAINING ISSUES THIS
FALL.
AND DURING THE NEXT LEGISLATIVE
SESSION WE THANK YOU ALL AGAIN
AND RESPECTFULLY MEMBERS WE URGE
YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANKS WHEN
THIS PLACE.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
NANCY TRAVEL WITH CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA.
WE ARE ALSO IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL WE APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
WORKING TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS THAT HAVE
BEEN MADE ARE ACTUALLY TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS AND DO NOT UNDERMINE.
THE IMPORTANT CONSUMER
PROTECTION ASPECTS OF THE BILL.
AND AS WE MOVE INTO NEXT I HOPE
WE CAN ALL WORK TOGETHER TO
DEFEND THIS LANDMARK CALIFORNIA
LAW I'M SURE MANY OF YOU READ
THE NEW YORK TIMES ARTICLE JUST
YESTERDAY.
ABOUT THE EFFORTS BY INDUSTRY TO
IMMEDIATELY MOVE TO WORK THROUGH
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION TO
PREEMPT OUR LAW HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
SO AS WE GO INTO TWO THOUSAND
AND NINETEEN THERE WILL BE.
A STRONG WORK THAT WE NEED TO DO
HERE TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR LAW
IS MOVING FORWARD.
AND THAT CALIFORNIANS DO HAVE
THE PRIVACY PROTECTIONS THEY
DESERVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OUR NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE OF MISTER CHAIR
CHRIS MCKAY WE ON BEHALF OF THE
COMPUTING TECHNOLOGY INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION AND WE SHARE THE
SUPPORT ARGUMENTS THAT MISS
BOOT.
MADE ON BEHALF OF THE CAL
CHAMBER THANK YOU THANK YOU
MATCH NEXT PLEASE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS LARA BUT
WITH TECH NET ASSOCIATE OR
COMMENTS ABOUT CAL CHAMBER.
MATCH NEXT.
MAUREEN MAHONEY ON BEHALF OF
CONSUMERS UNION WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR WORK ON THIS BILL.
WE SUPPORT EFFORTS TO ENACT
FIXES TO THE C. CPA THAT ARE
TRULY TECHNICAL IN NATURE AND
THAT RETAIN THE PURPOSE AND
INTENT OF THE BILL.
ADDITION WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH LAWMAKERS TO ENACT
MORE SUBSTANTIAL ON
COMPREHENSIVE REFORMS TO
CALIFORNIA'S PRIVACY AND
SECURITY FRAMEWORK NEXT YEAR
THANK YOU THANK YOU MUCH NEXT
PLEASE.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBER STIR TALKS
ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION I JUST LIKE TO THANK
YOU AND YOUR STAFF OF A LOT OF
WORK WENT INTO THIS --
STAFF ON LEADERSHIP ON BOTH
SIDES WE WANNA MAKE SURE THAT
THAT RECOGNIZE --
IT IN AGAIN OR WE URGE AND I
THOUGHT THANK YOU THANK YOU MUCH
NEXT WEEK.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR MARIS MY NAME
IS FRED NO WE'RE REPRESENTING
THE PHARMACEUTICAL RESEARCH AND
MANUFACTURERS OF AMERICA AS WELL
AS THE A LS LOU GEHRIG'S
DISEASE.
COLIN WEST CHAPTER IN SUPPORT
CLINICAL TRIALS ARE KEY AND THIS
WILL ALLOW THEM TO GO FOR
SEAMLESSLY THANK YOU.
BUT MATCH NEXT PLACE.
HAVE ANY ANDERSON ON BEHALF OF
THE RETAIL INDUSTRY LEADERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT ECHO THE
COMMENTS MADE BY THE CHAMBER
THANK YOU THANK YOU MUCH NEXT
WEEK.
THE A BARRACK ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA LIKE SCIENCE
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
MUCH.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS TERRY
THOMAS ON BEHALF OF THE MOTION
PICTURE ASSOCIATION OF AMERICA
WE ALIGN OURSELVES WITH THE
COMMENTS OF THE CHAMBER AND
SPORTED A BILL.
THANK YOU MUCH NEXT PLEASE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN WITH MAUREEN
HIGGINS REPRESENTING AMERICA'S
HEALTH INSURANCE PLANS ANTHEM
BLUE CROSS BIO COME IN THE
ADVANCED MEDICAL TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
KEVIN KELLY ON BEHALF OF
INTERNET ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU MUCH NEXT
WAYS.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS KEVIN
GOULD WITH CALIFORNIA BANKERS
ASSOCIATION WE ALSO LIKE TO
THANK THE AUTHOR STAFF AND
STAKEHOLDERS FOR THEIR WORK ON
THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU
MUCH.
JERRY MEMBER FROST BUCKLEY WITH
THE PERSONAL TRANSFORMATION IN
SUPPORT.
THE NEXT PLACE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN RECORDING JONES
ON THE CALIFORNIA CREDIT UNION
LEAGUE ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT PLACE.
CHAIR MEMBERS JOHN TREATMENT
DISSOCIATION A CALIFORNIA LIFE
AND HEALTH INSURANCE COMPANIES
WANT SUPPORT THANK YOU MUCH IT'S
PLACE.
SAMANTHA CORBIN I WOULD LIKE TO
AFFILIATE MY COMMENTS WITH MY
COLLEAGUES OVER AT CONSUMERS
UNION AND LIKE TO THANK THE
AUTHORS AND STAFF FOR THEIR
DILIGENT WORK IN KEEPING THIS
BILL TO PRIMARILY TECHNICAL
LANGUAGE --
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF ELECTRONIC
FOUND FRONTIER FOUNDATION
PRIVACY RIGHTS CLEARINGHOUSE
CONSUMER FEDERATION OF AMERICA.
MEDIA LANDS ACCESS HUMBOLDT.
THAT'S ALL OF THEM.
GREAT THANK YOU MUCH NEXT PLACE.
AS CHAIR MEMBERS JOHN DORY ON
BEHALF OF THE CIVIL JUSTICE
USHERS IN CALIFORNIA WANNA THANK
THE JOINT AUTHORS AT COMMITTEE
STAFF LEADERSHIP STAFF.
WAS A LOT OF WORK THINK WE GOT
TO GET PLACE WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT THANK MATCH NEXT PLEASE.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS COUNTY
DELGADO WITH A CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MUCH NEXT PLACE.
GOOD AFTERNOON IVAN ALTAMURA I'M
HALF THE CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN FIRST
OBSERVERS ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR CONSUMER
PRIVACY WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE THE STAFF IN THE
AUTHORS FOR ALL THEIR WORK ON
THIS INLAND ECHO THE COMMENTS OF
THE CONSUMER ATTORNEYS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
PLACEMENT.
I AM ELIZABETH POLICE YEAH I'M
VICE PRESIDENT OF COMMON SENSE
KIDS ACTION AND AS CO SPONSORS
OF THE SPELL.
FIRST OF ALL I'VE NEVER BEEN
PART OF SUCH A LONG LINE --
WE WANT TO THANK THE AUTHORS FOR
OF FOCUSING LARGELY ON TECHNICAL
FIXES IN THIS BILL AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE NEXT SESSION
TO STRENGTHEN PROTECTIONS FOR
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS THANK YOU.
WHICH I CONCEPTS TO TO SUPPORT
LINE FOR A SUPPORT OF MY SEAT
SERVICE TAX BILL.
WE THINK ABOUT IT.
MISTER CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
PAT SENCILLA HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA MORTGAGE BANKERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
MUCH NEXT PLEASE.
HI CHRISTY WITH SOME HALF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY BANKING
NETWORK AND THANK YOU NEXT
PLACE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MURS AND GERMAN
MURS ABOUT THE AMERICAN
INSURANCE ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN WAS BURNING
OROZCO BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
CABLE TELECOMMUNICATIONS ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AND MISS
HERTZBERG WILL TALK WE'RE GOING
TO DIE SOMETIME.
THANK YOU DITTO A JIMMY WORK
CALIFORNIA NEWS PUBLISHERS
ASSOCIATION WHEN I THINK OF THE
CHAIR BOTH SENATORS FOR THE
AMENDMENT THAT ADDRESSES THE
CONCERNS THAT WE'VE RAISED.
OUR WE'RE GLAD TO SEE THAT
YOU'VE RECOGNIZED THAT THERE
STONE ISSUE WITH REGARD TO THE
ADVERTISING ASPECT OF THIS BILL
AND OTHER FIRST AMENDMENT ISSUES
WITH YOU AND YOUR STAFF IN.
ADDRESSING THOSE THANK YOU THANK
YOU EXPLAINS.
JENNIFER SAMBA HAVE THE
BIOTECHNOLOGY INNOVATION
ORGANIZATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT PLACE RAINY
PARKING HAVE TO CONSUMER DATA
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
I CAN EXPRESS FIELDING GRIEVES
ON BEHALF OF THE ADVANCED
MEDICAL TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
MUCH OSKOL [inaudible]
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
ABOUT THAT [inaudible]
RIGHT.
LET'S BRING BACK THE COMEY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
OF MISTER OBERNOLTE GO AHEAD
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OF
SENATOR LOTT SENATOR HERTZBERG
ONE THANK YOU BOTH FOR YOUR WORK
ON THIS ISSUE.
I RECOGNIZE THAT THE TIMING.
OF THE BILLS WAS OUT OF OUR
CONTROL ON THE FIRST BILL I KNOW
YOU WORK VERY HARD ON AND THE
TIMING WAS VERY SHORT ON THAT IN
THIS ONE I REALIZE THAT WE'RE
UNDER TIME PRESSURE JUST BECAUSE
THERE'S SO LITTLE TIME LEFT
CONCESSIONS SO.
NORMALLY LATEAMENDMENTS AND
THINGS LIKE THAT CASE --
YOU KNOW IT WAS IT WAS WHAT WE
HAD TO DO AND I'M GLAD THAT
WE'RE TAKING THIS ACTION THIS
YEAR INSTEAD OF WAITING FOR NEXT
YEAR ALTHOUGH I'M SURE NEXT YEAR
WILL BE HAVING.
MORE DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THIS.
I WANTED TO HAVE.
BRIEF CONVERSATION THOUGH ABOUT
ONE THING THAT CONCERNS ME ABOUT
THE RECENT AMENDMENTS TO THE
BILL AND THAT'S REMOVING.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S A PLACE
IN THE PRIMACY OF THE RIGHT OF
PRIVATE ACTION --
DO WE HAVE A OF ROBUST
DISCUSSION IN THE ORIGINAL BILL
ABOUT THIS AND I KNOW THAT THERE
WAS --
STRONG FEELINGS ON BOTH SIDES
WITH THE COMPROMISE THAT WAS
REACHED.
WAS THAT THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
HAD PRIMACY AND I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROSECUTE
VIOLATORS.
BEFORE THE PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION COULD BE EXERCISED IN SO
I WONDER IF YOU COULD WALK ME
THROUGH JUST FOR A MINUTE THE
REASONING BEHIND REMOVING THAT
AND THIS RECENT AMENDMENT.
TRAINED JOURNALISTS OF THE
OPINION THAT HE IS NOT A
REGULATOR.
THAT HE IS A LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICER AND FELT THAT ON WHAT WE
WERE DOING BY VIRTUE OF CREATING
THIS NEW PROCESS WHEREBY HE HAD
TO REVIEW EVERY CLAIM.
NOT AND WE WE INUNDATE HIS
OFFICE WITH EVERYTHING UNDER THE
SUN PROJECT IN THE THIRTY DAY
DEADLINE.
BUT THAT IT WE LITERALLY TURN
HIM IN THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION REGULATOR AND HE FELT
THAT THAT WASN'T REALLY THE
APPROPRIATE ROLE.
AND ANSWER CAME FROM.
OKAY I I CAN WE TALK ABOUT IS A
POINT OF VIEW YOU KNOW IT'S HITS
--
IT'S NOT UNIQUE IN THIS BILL HE
HAS THAT RIGHT IN --
OTHER AREAS THAT THE STATE HAS
ESTABLISHED REGULATION OVER.
OUGHT TO TAKE ACTION AND YOU
KNOW HE CAN CHOOSE WHETHER NOT
TO EXERCISE IT AND FUTURE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S MAY MAY OR
MAY NOT SHARE HIS VIEW POINT ON
IT SO.
I DIDN'T SEE WHAT THE THE HARM
WAS IN LEAVING THAT END BECAUSE
ALL HE HAS TO DO IS NOTHING.
AND THE PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION
STILL WHICH SO I DON'T KNOW WHY
WE WERE TAKING THAT OUT.
BUT YOU KNOW HAVING SAID THAT I
THINK CERTAINLY THESE AMENDMENTS
DO FAR MORE.
GOOD THAN HARM I AM HOPEFUL THAT
NEXT YEAR AS WE HAVE SUBSEQUENT
DISCUSSION ABOUT HOW FURTHER
AMENDMENTS TO THIS --
WE CAN WE CAN INCLUDE THE
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE FINE TUNE AT A TO
HONOR THE SPIRIT OF THE
COMPROMISE THAT WAS YOU KNOW.
THAT REALLY WAS A BIG PART OF
THE DISCUSSION ROW KNOWS THAT
CHAIRMAN KNOWS THAT HE KNOWS A
BIG ISSUE ABOUT WHAT TO DO AND
HOW TO PUT THE AG IN THIS THING
BUT QUITE FRANKLY WHEN HAVING
THOSE DISCUSSIONS WERE DEBATING
WITH HIS OFFICE.
THEY ARE TRYING TO YOU KNOW
NEGOTIATE SOMETHING THAT THE
PROPONENT MR MCTAGGART WOULD
AGREE TO THAT WOULD GET TO THE
VERY ESSENCE OF AND I THINK THE
NUB OF WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
SOME KIND OF PRE REVIEW.
SO THINGS ARE AUTOMATICALLY
LITIGATED AND THERE WAS SOME
PROCESS BUT I DO THINK THAT IT
AS WE FOCUS ON IT NEXT YEAR IF
YOU CAN HELP US ON THAT HELP
SQUAD THAT COME WITH AN IDEA
THAT WOULD BE GREAT SO THERE IS
SOME ESSENCE TO WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING.
ABOUT TRYING TO AVOID EVERYTHING
GOING TO LITIGATION AKA
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANKS FOR THE COMMENT I WILL
CONTINUE THAT DIALOGUE AND IN
THE NEXT YEAR SO BECAUSE THAT
WAS ONE OF MY CONCERNS ARE ALSO.
A BUT THE WE DID RECEIVE A
LETTER FROM THE EIGHTIES OFFICER
OF BASICALLY OUTLINING SOME OF
THE CONCERNS ALSO SO WE DON'T
WANT TO JAM SOMETHING DOWN HIS
THROAT YOU KNOW WITHOUT.
HIM COME TRY TO COMPLY ELISE SO
WILL CONTINUE THAT DIALOGUE
[inaudible]
ABSOLUTELY SIR.
ANY FURTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
SCENE AND THEN LET ME LET ME
THANK A CENTERS FOR FOR YOU WORK
AS WELL AS YOU TEAMS ARE FOR
YOUR HARD WORK.
NOT ONLY FOR FOR THE LAST TWO
WEEKS BUT ALSO FOR THE ENTIRE
YEAR.
AND YOUR TEAM TO TEAMS HAVE BEEN
GREAT I THINK PARTICULARLY IN
LIGHT OF FACT THAT WE ONLY HAVE
LIKE. TEN DAYS OR SO.
OUGHT TO WORK ON THE CELL
AMENDMENTS AND AND I WANT TO
TAKE A SENATOR DODD FOR ALLOWING
US TO USE YOUR BILL AB ELEVEN
TWENTY ONE AS A VEHICLE TO
ADDRESSING SOME OF THESE ISSUES.
AS WE ALL KNOW WE DID RECEIVE
LETTERS FROM VERY STAKEHOLDERS
AMONG THEM ALL THE CHAMBER I'LL
BASICALLY OUTLINING A NUMBER OF
ISSUES THAT THEY WOULD LIKE FOR
US.
TO ADDRESS AND ARE WE WERE ABLE
TO ADDRESS SOME OF THEM A
HANDFUL OF THEM WITHOUT.
ELEVEN TWENTY ONE AND AS TO THE
REST OF THEM WE WILL DEFINITELY
BE LOOKING AT THEM ARE MORE
CLOSELY ARM TYPE OF MEETING WE
WILL ONE OF YOU KNOW BASICALLY
WORK WITH EVERYONE TO SEE WHAT
THEIR ISSUES ARE.
ON SALE WOULD DO THAT --
AND ONE AFFORD ALSO AND I THINK
MY COMMITTEE STAFF AS WELL
THEY'VE BEEN WORKING LONG HOURS
OF THE LAST TO LAST WEEK'S ESOS
I WANT TO THANK HIM.
SO WITHOUT --
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
[inaudible]
ARE.
ALRIGHT VOMITED FACTORY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
MOTIONS DO PASSED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CHAO TYPE CHAO AYE
KILEY.
KILEY AYE BAKER.
BAKER AYE BERMAN.
BERMAN AYE CALDERON CALDERON AYE
GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE AYE RAYOS [inaudible]
REGIS I CONGRATULATIONS WILL
PASS IT AUTHOR MAKES MEMBERS
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WE HAVE WE HAVE ONE MORE BILL
THAT'S ALL LARA BILL.
PLEASE CALL THE UP TO MEMBERS
[inaudible]
KILEY [inaudible]
KILEY NO.
BERMAN BERMAN AYE.
MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE RAYOS.
REYES I THINK MEMBERS